[Music]
recently Lego announced a new figurine
it's gonna be added to their lineup it's
the Lego stay-at-home-dad
yes there it is the stay at home with
the child with an extra-large head our
child also doubles as a cookie jar yeah
exactly that's what it looks like anyway
this is real there's gonna be a lego
stay-at-home dad that they've come out
with and I think it's a great idea there
are a lot of stay-at-home dads and Legos
trying to reflect the times that we live
in the new figurine will be available in
June but Lego just released a commercial
for it we got a hold of it check it out
Lego introduces our newest figure it's
stay-at-home Lego dad he's a modern dad
in modern times thanks sweetie
first let's put the baby down and have
some alone time oh no looks like
state-owned Lego dad decided to get high
now he's spying on the neighbor mrs.
Johnson with his binoculars
please bend over please bend over yes
time for some online poker careful stay
at home leggo dad remember what happened
last time
Oh No stay at home lego dad bet you big
he lost the house mine is love get high
again oh no his wife's home and she
thinks
now she's serving him divorce papers I'm
sleeping with my male assistant good guy
Colton
well guess it's time to put the toaster
in the bathtub it's day huh they go down
toaster sold separately
he died in the end yeah look at that
picture I love that picture of him in
the tub with Nexus 4 hive
[Laughter]
you